hello everybody welcome to this special
interview for Collider I'm your host
John Roca I've got an actor writer
producer rapper singer comic book
creator VJ and model to interview today
he's been the star of such films as baby
boy for brothers Annapolis flight of the
Phoenix and he's been a mainstay in two
of the biggest franchises over the last
few years fast and furious and
transformers but today here's he is here
to talk about his new film a police
drama called black and blue ladies
gentleman please welcome to Collider the
great Tyrese Gibson how are you man hmm
introduction made me nervous look don't
be nervous Matt you're in good hands if
I really accomplished all that
yeah that's Wow what's up everybody it's
my first time on here man thanks for
coming on really appreciate y'all thank
you for having me and thank you all for
tuning in y'all better get ready I don't
know what I might say oh great I'm happy
to be involved in that that's gonna
happen this you're here like I mention
you're here to talk about this film
black and blue man is a really
interesting film gritty crime drama here
got the police being corrupt got
criminals involved to police now me
Harris leading this thing with you right
by her side tell me what spoke to you
about this film and attracted you to be
a part of this obviously working with a
friend of yours I think Dion Taylor what
else attracted you about being a part of
this project man well when you working
on a movie that you know Harley what
normally doesn't make you know it gives
you a different kind of inspiration to
to get in there and do the best you can
with every moment and I think the
biggest thing became it's one thing to
have picket signs and be screaming and
doing marches and being rebellious
against the system and it's another
thing to put that exact same messaging
in a movie you can't expect people that
don't live in the ghettos or the inner
city who are black or Latino who have to
live kind of in this pressure cooker
that we're living in you can't expect
them to go down there
and be a part of the Marches and say now
that I'm here I understand how you feel
so they tend to look at things through
their timelines or through their phones
or through TV this black and blue movie
is really really crazy because Naomi
Harris's character played her name is
Alisha in the movie she's a two-time war
vet has been in Afghanistan she takes a
leave of absence because her mother
passed away she comes back home to New
Orleans where she's from there and she
becomes a rookie cop her police partners
say to her on a ride-along stay in the
car right gotta go handle something
she's like well I got to stay in the car
yeah she hears a gunshot she gets out
the car there in front of this big
warehouse she senses something is going
on she goes in she hits the record
button on her body cam and she's able to
capture on her body cam her three police
officer colleagues murdering
execution-style three black boys in the
middle of a drug deal and because she
captures the murder on her body cam
they're on a mission throughout the
movie to try and kill her to stop her
from turning that body cam footage in it
seems like you play an old friend of
hers that she goes to for help because
everyone seems to be closing the doors
on her and doesn't want to get involved
what's your relationship to her am i
guessing that that's right
yeah I mean I do know her I guess
wouldn't call it a relationship because
she was friends with my cousin okay was
played by an FSO and Andy in the movie
but yeah they were you know the best of
friends they'd been to juvenile hall a
couple of times together
and she decided to stay in the hood and
live the street life and Alicia decided
to go to the military yeah and yeah so
it's it's it's one of the movies believe
it or not where someone said to me
during a press junket that she sat down
in the theater and from the moment the
movie started she felt like somebody
from the back row put their foot on her
neck and I would not take the neck off
of her foot off her neck for two hours
and she was screaming and yelling at the
screen she was jumping over fences
because of the character was jumping
over fences and she was like fully
engaged yelling at the screen she was
giving people high-fives in the theater
she didn't know and it is a thriller it
is a ride it is aggressive it is it's
the furthest thing from preachy I don't
want my voice to put anybody to sleep
but yeah it's it's pretty real man I'm
really really honored to be a part of a
real movie with a real topic yeah based
on what we're living every day well
isn't just about the corruption to
tyrese i mean i think what we see from
the trailer what people have seen from
the movie who've seen it early is you
see her struggling with this idea of her
being a black cop and like where's her
allegiance lie is it to her community is
it to the blues where does she let her
community since what's why the title is
what it is for the movie but that's also
an issue that gets highlighted it has
been documented in articles but we
haven't really seen that many movies
about it mainstream movies about it so
that's another positive about this movie
that they tackle this with someone like
Naomi Harris and you of course going
also I appreciate you bro um you know I
just think often about making sure that
I'm being responsible by saying that not
all police officers are bad right i've
called 9-1-1 plenty of times for help
and they've always helped also I've seen
them do things that was not helping
right and there's this aggressive kind
of friction and tension for many years
between the police and policing in the
inner city and
you know this movie sheds light on that
in a real way but what's interesting is
this right I often think about Eric
garner mm-hmm
right and him being choked and stay with
me y'all I'm going somewhere every
Garner gets choked and he's tapping the
officers arm while saying I can't
breathe and he gets killed right there
on the spot and there was 12 police
officers standing by right looking at
this all happen none of their body cam
footage has been turned in to this day
and none of them spoke out about the
officer who choked Eric garner right
rather black or white so that's the blue
code that's that's what we're talking
about now there's a difference in
snitching versus being a whistleblower
mm-hmm see Trump right now is dealing
with a lot of heat because somebody
overheard something was some type of
corruption and intentions and coverup
and now he's dealing with somebody that
says well I took an oath to office to do
the right thing I see something I must
say something in the hood is snitching
when you do something stupid you get
caught and then you want to take a bunch
of people down with you right right
don't want to say no names with
Takashi's six nine okay so but when you
whistle blowing we're looking at
I took a oath to an honorable I am my
salary is from taxpayers dollars and if
I see something I must say something so
shame on all of those officers who stood
there and witnessed err gonna get choked
and and never decided to speak out yeah
uh you know his mother will never have
their son ever again yeah I think
there's a balance here and I think
that's what you're highlighting here
what you're talking about there are good
and bad in anything so to be generalized
one way or the other I think is always
dangerous you know no matter cuz you can
say all those people in the hood they're
all criminals or those cops they're all
corrupt and and there's no way to reach
a compromise or an understanding or a
or a piece in this and look the main
person of this film is a policewoman and
in fighting other corrupt police cops
doesn't mean that everyone is corrupt
against it were just meeting this
particular set are for the narrative of
the people that's involved with the
murder a guy caught up they don't want
anybody to see that right and she's
trying to do the right thing which is to
protect and serve the effect that the
oath honorable said this pivot to Naomi
we mention her a couple times already
what was it like working with her cuz I
mean this is a British woman coming in
to play you know a a black woman from
the hood from the worlds as you
mentioned what was that experience like
for her too she did you guys have a lot
of conversations about this or it all
just professional and then just get on
the job no I you know I got there maybe
two weeks before it was time to film I
believe she arrived a little early as
well and you know there was an
uncomfortable moment that happened
between me and Naomi because I said to
her you know we have some really really
heavy scenes and beyond the words as a
bunch of looks there's a bunch of
moments and nuances and if it's possible
I'd like to go to your house or a
restaurant or somewhere and meet up so
that we can just put the dialogue up on
his feet and peel back the layers and
really go there so that we're not
figuring out these nuances while we're
paying for two hundred people on a crew
yeah that's fair point and she was
hesitant about it because her process is
she's not used to collaborating like
that just like I'm gonna do much I got
my lines you got your lines good luck
yeah and it made all the difference in
the world that she said yes something
else does interesting is she retired
from acting really yes okay um and was
approaching a year of saying I quit
I'm done Wow she's been at it since she
was nine years old coming off of an
Oscar nomination with moonlight she says
she wanted to open up a nail salon like
random thing that's kind of awesome it
is
yes you know you go you live a life of
so many extreme yeah colors and and
antics and and you know scale and then
we all just want to do simple things
when it comes to how we unpack yeah
so this script came across her desk
agents and managers sent it to her and
this movie brought her out of retirement
Wow
that's to our benefit because she's an
incredibly talented actress and this
looks like an incredible role for her to
play I want to ask you how intense is
frank grillo to work with bro I only did
so many scenes would hit okay but you
could sense it right Frank is crazy he's
a monster in his movie really a monster
yeah I interviewed him for the deep cut
and one of my favorite interviews ever
done sweet guy but he radiates the you
know that kind of intensity and strength
so yeah he's a savage man yeah
did you is the reason why anxiety
attacks is happening around this movie
he's unbearable
yes movie man he just does not stop you
can see it you know you see just from
the scenes we've been able to see
already the ferocity with which he
brings to that role let me ask you a
kind of a play more playful question did
you want to take my Coulter's coat at
the end of the movie when a rat day oh
is pimp
yeah idea want that jacket I tried to
steal it when it was hanging up in his
trailer like his door was open he was
getting some fresh air and I think he
was in the bathroom and his coat was
hanging up and I was like here's my shot
and our characters in the movie don't
get along so I was like maybe I need to
create some motivation yeah because he's
wondering where's my sexy fur jacket are
you working with Deon Taylor on this one
man he is he's someone that just got
announced this morning that his show
free agents that is gonna come out come
out hell through Lionsgate now he's been
working I heard off-camera that you guys
kind of developed this together or wor
talked about it way back when so how
excited are you for this to be happening
and will you be involved can you say
what what involvement
happiness well we'll see okay you know I
was a co-producer on that that movie and
when we tried to get a greenlit at the
time it didn't pan out we don't think we
were in a very different state of black
Hollywood yeah and us being here having
real projects about real stories and
topics is what we all want to accomplish
and so yeah I think Dion is definitely
gonna look in my direction
yeah because I've always wanted to do a
football movie and I just love with the
idea that movie is yeah yeah to let
people know about the movie it's a it's
a group of professional football players
to turning a crime to get back at the
owners who are exploring and under
paying them are they looking at it as
the the vein of heat and the town to
read more about it Jeff Snyder wrote
about it for collider.com she can go to
see it there Joe Baca Liz involved write
in the script as well hope I said that
name right let me ask you this you speak
about football and you see here there's
a lot of action season are you getting
up there man is it harder and harder to
put your body through this kind of stuff
like be honest man no okay girl you're
still in good health stuck in handling
all the bumps and bruises you eat and it
shows up man you know it's it's I've
never been a real fan of the gym even
though I've been in and out of shape too
many times and this movie me looking
scruffy ashy with crusty lips and put on
a few pounds that was all with the
intentions of being the opposite of
Roman Pearce being the opposite of all
of these guys that you're used to me
being lean and mean and in shape and
looking you know it's it's hard to sell
grit when you're like extra handsome and
fly so I had I had to tap in to
something super dusty and and and and
and make people care yeah about this
role that I was playing so it all worked
out yeah it looks fantastic I can't wait
to see it myself might be going to a
screen tonight to see this thing so I'm
looking forward to it
I want to ask you about a couple other
things certainly I got to ask you about
Morbius you
a outlet that covers a lot of superhero
comic book movies you've instagrammed
some videos and some pictures from the
set they're worth working with with
director Espinoza and tell me about can
you say anything first of all your
experience on it and you're playing the
agents tribe which you outed so I'm not
you know revealing anything big tell me
what
what's your feeling out which experience
are we looking forward to with this
thing well you know ever since Black
Panther happened for us in the black
community and we're finally able to step
into black being being a black superhero
we got Luke Cage we got various you know
african-american comic book characters
and agents shroud from Morbius was
actually white mm-hmm and so they slid
me in there and asked me to use some
some tanning oil
so I darkened up nicely for the role but
yeah it's it's a game changer when I
daniel espinosa is is insane as a
filmmaker he kept us all on edge he
really really was focused on the nuances
I play opposite Jared Leto Oscar Award
winner and he's all dark and mischievous
and very layered and I'm just trying to
get to the bottom of what's going on and
what he's involved in so I can get to
the bottom of what's happening yeah cuz
shrouded Morbius have a long history in
the comic books and so is that gonna be
explored in this movie even more of
course we'll have a villain but like is
this going to be explored even more man
I think in detail
well I'm looking forward to it that's
for damn sure cuz I love that you're
involved in this and seeing your career
you know you've done so many things bro
coming out from baby boy working with
singleton by the way you know
heartbroken for his passing as well I'm
sure you know four brothers another one
that you do such great work in like how
what do you think his legacy is as a
director
well his legacy as a human being even
man his legacy as of right now is you
know the worst of the world get to
experience the fruits of John Singleton
you know him putting on these writers
and directors and wardrobe stylist and
head of makeup and special effects and
Steadicam operators there's so many
people that didn't and couldn't get a
job in Hollywood because they were black
and John went out of his way to make
sure that you know if you're capable of
doing the job I'm gonna put my people on
mm-hm and change the game and being as
that baby boy was my first movie ever
yeah yeah I've seen the majority of the
crew were african-american and Latino I
actually thought that was normal until I
went and started doing all these other
movies and then I said you know if
someone becomes a little more
intentional about diversity on their
movie sets with women men rather gay or
straight just giving people an
opportunity to do their job when they're
very capable of doing their jobs I think
gonna make for a better Hollywood
absolutely man well I think we're seeing
that now we're in a transition place
where that's happening more more and me
as a Latino I'm extremely happy about
I'm sure you must be as there's a
difference in being on camera and
directing true diverse versus the crew
member yeah yeah it's 1,200 crew members
on some of these movies I do right and
you don't see too many of us around yeah
and I'm like yeah don't we want to feed
our families too we got we want to be
living the middle class and put our kids
in private school we want to go from one
movie to the next to the next to the
next these crew members are working more
often an actor mm-hmm right good point
yeah because I mean Raj X getting
involved here I gotta ask you about you
two franchises I definitely gotta ask
about transformers I defend those movies
all the time um well
known for loving those films I think
Michael Bay does fantastic fun with
those films people try to put way too
much seriousness on those films they are
fun fun movies you do great work in them
there been rumors that they're gonna tie
it back into the new bumblebee stuff is
gonna tie back in to Michael Bay's
transformers any chance you're making a
comeback at least in this property in
this franchise you know I'm hot in these
streets right now baby but they might
want me to come back
I would love to man yeah yeah Michael
Bay is one of my favorites he's loud and
aggressive but I really I know his heart
he's very loyal and you know yeah he
changed my life man I think baby boy was
movie number one too fast too furious
right then Annapolis then waist-deep and
then around that area came transformers
and the crazy thing is I met Michael Bay
on the set of bad boys - in Miami while
we were shooting too fast too furious I
got invited to set by Will Smith and
that's when I actually first met Michael
Bay yeah and it's just been cool knowing
him over the years you know he's got
reputation or this and that but I like
the guy I think he's stand-up and very
loyal to the people that he's been
rocking with for many years and whatever
he's doing whatever whatever he's
blowing up called me man I'm ready all
right done and done now what about the
Fast and Furious stuff you don't know I
could ask you about that other stuff
yeah all that all the messes well the
nine just rapped right right now how
excited were you to get back into that
the world again oh man it's been 17
years for me so you know it felt like a
real family reunion to get back and be
on the set we just announced that cardi
B is in it we got John Sena right who's
stepping in with a role that's gonna
shock a lot of people are gonna be like
huh you know
so you know the thing is this fast
universe is a really big torch man yeah
because you know this movie gets
released and every man woman and child
is seeing it mm-hmm 20:21 will make
twenty years since the first fast came
out come that's crazy man and if you're
17 18 20 years old you literally grew up
on fast right and now you probably have
kids for yourself that's also watching
fast it's a generational thing that we
pride ourselves on and I think fast 9 is
gonna piss doc Donald Trump off oh no
really
oh absolutely it represents everything
that he's not okay diversity inclusion
people saying it doesn't matter what
your race background you know bank
account net worth we have one mission in
mind and we have to do this together in
order to accomplish that yeah that's one
of the one of the big positives about
the Fast and Furious franchise that sure
always been a diverse franchise want to
ask you about one last thing and they
told this to me off air and I kind of
lost my mind cuz I'm a massive fan
having grown up in the 80s of Teddy
Pendergrass and going back I just got
back into records and you bought a
record players so listen to Teddy's
voice come over I'm hearing this this
this thing that you're doing a Teddy
Pendergrass biopic lee daniels is
attached is it gonna be called love TKO
what can you tell me about this I like
the title teddy bear yeah okay I like
that
yeah life story of Teddy Pendergrass you
know some folks don't notice but I'm a
singer first yes seven eight albums
toured around the world as a singer and
transitioned into acting and the style
of music I sing is its R&B soul rhythm
and blues soul and it's everything that
Teddy is so I knew him five six years
before he passed I was in the hospital
and he was on his deathbed praying for
him was with him I got so much footage
of us hanging out he took me to the
crash site
a lot that caused them to be
quadriplegic and you know he just really
took me under his wing and yeah it's its
way I cannot wait to get this movie done
yeah is this gonna happen because that
Marvin Gaye biopic that was supposed to
happen with Jesse L I was waiting on
that when it never came to be can you
dance is gonna happen I I don't know
what's going on with that but this is
gonna happen okay very real yeah Teddy
deserves a film and a lot and his
background of people may not know me I
love y'all man listen man yeah I need
y'all to help me to make a statement I'm
not talented enough to figure out a way
to get you the viewer to say you know
what
nothing else matters this weekend but
going to support black and blue mm-hmm
but I will tell you this as they
continue to greenlight slave movies at
studios that do a hundred million and
got all these awards and everything
lined up I posed the question how many
more slave movies hmm we know that's a
part of our history that's what we dealt
with but getting behind movies like this
that's gonna have you wiping your sweat
screaming at the screen the adrenaline
the energy and everything is so crazy
yeah all while falling in love with this
world and these characters in success
more movies that speak to what we
actually live every day will be made
yeah
and just on the grounds of that alone
now I know y'all don't know me
personally so I apologize okay right
there I know you don't know me
personally so I apologize in advance but
you will never run into me and be able
to say bro I never wanted to watch your
black and blue movie
you sold me on it I spent my money and
it was trash this movie you are going to
love
every moment of this movie and you're
gonna become you might go from hater to
the greatest promoter because you might
go into this thing with your doubts and
you converting means more than anything
and I also want to invite people that
know nothing about black people Latinos
nothing about the ghettos the inner city
or this boilerplate that we're living in
every day just being who we are in
America under Trump's regime but I want
to invite you to come in and say you
know let me let me get this movie a shot
because I just want to understand more
about things that I don't understand you
should never be the guy to say I don't
have cancer so I don't care about it my
kids are not sleeping in cages at the
border it's not my nephew my niece so I
don't care there's no human and sex
trafficking happening in my life so I
don't care we are living in some trying
times right now and one would also say
well you're famous you got money you
drive this and live in that well they
never stop Biggie Smalls from being
killed true or mock he had more money
than me yeah he sold more records than
me he was bigger than me he could afford
more security than me his murder to this
day is unsolved and you ask yourself
some real question how do you sleep at
night when you're aware of who said did
a raise and covered up this and you're
not gonna just speak out about what you
know yeah and so this character Naomi
Harris is playing is on a mission to get
this body cam footage into the station
because her moral compass is living up
to the oath that she took right to see
something and say something and she's
willing to risk her life to do it thanks
so much brother it was an awesome
pleasure man rish ate y'all attention
span out there there you go go see
watching go see black and blue it's out
go Tyrese teeth TV follow him at Tyrese
Gibson he's a he's an awesome follow
yeah let me tell you I need some
followers on Instagram eleven million
which man
come on follow me I need love people he
doesn't need love I'm trying to give it
to him his last 30 minutes all right
black and blue it's out there now go see
this thing from Dion Taylor Naomi Harris
and Tyrese Gibson to Mike Colter doing
some great work with Frank Grillo in
this thing this has been our interview
with Tyrese Gibbs and thanks for
watching John Roca Collider subscribe
we'll talk to you next time